[Musique]
comment tu peux ne pas aimer les
lumières et les décorations
c'est magnifique viens avec moi chez mes
parents pour la fête de noël abéhi toi
harper vous avez la relation parfaite et
les ma personne et je vais vraiment que
tout le monde le sache je me marie avec
elle je vais demander la permission à
son air frma demande autour de noël
une belle façon de combattre le
patriarcat
[Musique]
bof il ya un petit truc dont on devrait
parler tu te rappelles quand j'ai dit à
mes parents que j'étais gay eh bien
c'était pas tout à fait mais parfait
puis une seconde c'est notre super maman
apports et notre fonds se et jane n'ont
été demandé d'arrêter faire ça et
c'était pas écouté puisque tout va bien
voyage ils sont petits soucis ses
parents savent pas qu'on est ensemble ou
même qu'elle est gay alors quoi ses
parents pensent vraiment que leur fille
hétéro à ramener à la maison son amie
lesbienne danse aussi que je suis pas
gay est ce qu'ils ont déjà rencontré une
lesbienne
c'est le petit ami du secondaire de
harper est ce que tu as un petit ami en
fait je viens tout juste de reprendre
c'était un poseur ils posaient des
portes
ok c'est très difficile
de tracy à côté toi qui te pas vouloir
embrasser qu'est ce que tu fais dans le
placard je vois ici lsi terrifié de ce
que tout le monde pense je comprends ce
que c'est d'être amoureuse d'une
personne qui est trop effrayés pour
montrer au monde qu'elle est il fait
tout leur dire après les fêtes de tout
si tu sais à quel point c'est douloureux
devant la personne que j'aime choisir tu
me cacher chez vous je ne te cache pas
du tout c'est moi que ce cas ce n'est
pas le plus beau temps de l'année tout
le monde a une histoire différente
harper n'est pas prête ça ne veut pas
dire qu'elle ne t'aime pas de très
belles danses marteau saluer ce que vous
êtes
l'ex petit ami oui c'est moi john
l'ex-petite amie hétérosexuels deux avis
et je suis ici ce soir pour la
reconquérir
amusez vous ok je fais un super hétéro
et elle est fabuleuse
[Musique]